🎵 Intro (Instrumentale) 🎵
🎵 Tu m'as pris la main et j'ai su qu'il était temps 🎵
🎵 Mais maintenant c'est difficile de cacher ces sentiments à l'intérieur🎵
🎵 Tout ce qui est inconnu m'entoure 🎵
🎵 Mais je n'échouerai pas🎵
🎵 Je n'ai pas peur de tout ça 🎵
🎵 Je me sens homme 🎵
🎵Je me lèverai mais je ne tomberai pas 🎵
🎵 Pour la première fois 🎵
🎵 Maintenant je sais que  je suis le...🎵
🎵 BOOOOOOON 🎵
🎵 'Jamais été aussi prêt ~ 🎵
🎵 'Jamais senti aussi stable ~ 🎵
🎵 Je n'ai pas peur de tout ça 🎵
🎵Je me sens un homme, je me lèverai mais je ne tomberai pas 🎵
🎵 Tout a changé 🎵
🎵 Yeah 🎵
🎵 Ce serait drôle si je disais 🎵
🎵 Eh bien , la chose est faite 🎵
🎵 Tu m'as manqué 🎵
🎵 Je ne suis pas le bon 🎵
🎵 Si je suis tout seul 🎵
🎵 'Jamais été aussi prêt ~ 🎵
🎵 'Jamais senti aussi stable ~ 🎵
🎵 Je n'ai pas peur de tout ça 🎵
🎵 Je me sens un homme 🎵
🎵 Je me lèverai mais je ne tomberai pas 🎵
🎵 Instrumental 🎵
🎵 Je me battrai quelle que soit la façon 🎵
🎵 Toutes les nuits et tous les jours. 🎵
🎵 J'aimerai quelle que soit la façon 🎵
🎵 Toutes les nuits et tous les jours 🎵
🎵 Je me battrai quelle que soit la façon 🎵
🎵'Jamais été aussi prêt ~ 🎵
🎵 Je me sens prêt 🎵
🎵 'Jamais senti aussi stable ~ 🎵
🎵 Je n'ai pas peur du tout 🎵
🎵 Je me sens un homme 🎵
🎵Je me lèverai mais je ne tomberai pas 🎵
🎵 Musique : I Feel A Man - Frenetics 🎵
- Musique présente dans le court-métrage -
"La Première Fois" de Squeezie
(Univers tiré de : "Rainbow Six Siege")